Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Giorgio Fighera
François de Brabant: Allora,
la prima domanda, Aurelia,
che ti faccio è -
dovremmo spiegare perché
hai accettato di venire a parlare
di fronte al pubblico
di TEDxMilano oggi, su questo palco.
Aurelia Rivarola: Sì, alla mia età,
e senza essere mai salita su un palco,
ho fatto un po' di fatica ad accettare.
Però ho pensato che questa occasione
potesse essere veramente un momento
in cui diffondere qualcosa
a cui io, e tanti colleghi, ci dedichiamo.
Un momento in cui qualcosa
che finora è stato sussurrato
forse può venire gridato,
e cioè il diritto alla comunicazione.
Noi tutti diciamo che la comunicazione
è un fondamentale diritto umano.
Ma cosa facciamo quando
una persona non può parlare
e spesso non può adoperare
neanche le altre modalità comunicative
che tutti noi usiamo,
come i gesti, la mimica,
lo spostamento del corpo,
il linguaggio del corpo?
Beh, vivono una vita-
le persone che hanno
queste caratteristiche
vivono una vita molto isolata,
una vita in cui spesso non sono
neanche considerate capaci di pensare.
E allora ho pensato
che questa potesse essere l'occasione
per diffondere qualche cosa
che è conosciuto come nome
però non è conosciuto
a livello di comunità,
per cui quando c'è
una persona che non parla,
spesso si pensa che non possa pensare,
FdB: Ci fa molto piacere
che tu abbia scelto questo pubblico -
credo non a caso,
perché è un pubblico
di curiosi, aperti e innovativi,
per raccontare -
per affrontare questo tema
effettivamente molto delicato
e poco conosciuto.
Ecco, ma a chi è rivolta la CAA,
che poi ci spiegherai cos'è?
A.R.: La Comunicazione
Aumentativa, poi ne parleremo,
è rivolta a quei bambini, o adulti,
che per cause congenite -
cioè sono persone che hanno avuto
un'asfissia alla nascita
e hanno una paralisi cerebrale infantile;
sono le persone che vediamo in carrozzina
che spesso non riescono
neanche a muovere le mani
e ad avere alcuna autonomia;
persone con un ritardo cognitivo notevole,
spesso dovuto a cause genetiche,
malattie genetiche
che provocano ritardo intellettivo
e, per molte delle persone
che ne sono affette,
impossibilità a parlare.
Sono i bambini autistici;
sono bambini con disprassia di sviluppo.
E poi ci sono delle cause acquisite:
pensiamo a un ictus, a un trauma cranico,
persone che non riescono
più ad esprimersi.
Cause neurologiche evolutive:
sono tutte le forme
di malattia degenerativa.
Adesso si parla molto dei malati di SLA:
tutti i malati di SLA,
nelle fasi finali della loro vita,
non possono proprio parlare.
E già nelle prime fasi della malattia
riescono con fatica a parlare.
E poi ci sono delle cause temporanee.
Capita che nei reparti
di chirurgia maxilofacciale,
di terapia intensiva,
delle persone, anche temporaneamente,
non possono parlare.
E si è visto che per
queste persone, oltre al trauma,
si può capire quello che succede,
hanno anche meno adesione alle cure
e hanno dei ricoveri più lunghi.
È tanti anni che cerchiamo
di diffondere questo -
l'importanza della comunicazione,
anche temporaneamente.
E dei colleghi delle terapie intensive
tempo fa avevano detto:
ma se non parlano
curiamo meglio il corpo.
Come se questa fosse
l'unica cosa da curare.
Ecco, tutte queste persone
sono dei candidati
alla Comunicazione
Aumentativa Alternativa.
FdB: Ecco, con questo
hai allargato veramente -
sembrava un problema di nicchia,
invece può succedere anche a me.
Cioè, voglio dire,
la descrizione che hai fatto
apre moltissimo le possibilità
e quindi rende ancora
più importante sapere cos'è.
Abbiamo citato la sigla
e l'hai appena accennata un po',
ma CAA che cos'è?
AR: Volevo dire una cosa
su quello che hai detto.
Può succedere a tutti, speriamo di no,
però è importante pensare
che aiutare a comunicare
con queste persone
interessa anche noi.
Perché noi vogliamo comunicare con tutti,
quindi anche con chi non può parlare.
Quindi non solo come
destinatari dell'intervento,
ma anche come persone
che vogliono conoscere, stare con tutti
e non possono stare con queste persone.
FdB: A maggior ragione, adesso,
entriamo in che cos'è la CAA.
AR: CAA sta per Comunicazione
Aumentativa Alternativa.
Ed è tutto quello che può aiutare
una persona che non può parlare
a comunicare.
Quindi sono degli strumenti,
delle tecniche, degli ausili.
Ma soprattutto è la capacità
dei partner comunicativi
di interagire con queste persone
e di facilitarne la comunicazione.
FdB: Ecco, ma quando è nata?
A.R.: La Comunicazione Aumentativa -
i primi semi sono stati gettati
negli anni '60/'70
in Nord America e Nord Europa e -
F.d.B: Scusa se ti interrompo,
ma se ricordo bene
su dei fatti molto precisi.
A.R.: Sì.
Quando i reduci del Vietnam,
che avevano avuto traumi cranici,
non riuscivano più a parlare,
allora i logopedisti
dovevano far riemergere il linguaggio.
Era obbligatorio, perché
i sensi di colpa erano notevoli.
Quindi cercavano
di far riemergere il linguaggio,
però queste persone non riuscivano,
e non riuscivano nemmeno i logopedisti.
Invece, dando degli altri strumenti
riuscivano almeno a comunicare
ed essere, nella loro vita, protagonisti.
E lo facevano di nascosto,
nei primi tempi.
Finché questi strumenti,
queste tabelle usate con gli afasici -
a volte, delle tabelle con l'alfabeto
che la persona indicava
con le mani o con gli occhi -
poteva permettere una comunicazione.
Un po' alla volta, si è capito
che in certi casi il linguaggio
non poteva ritornare
e molte persone che venivano
dal campo dell'educazione -
ma anche dal campo della tecnologia,
perché hanno subito provato
con degli strumenti tecnologici,
si è riunita per fondare, nel Michigan,
la società che si chiama Isaac
e sta per "International Society
Augmentative Alternative Communication"
che cerca di diffondere
la Comunicazione Aumentativa nel mondo.
FdB: Ho portato un attimo fa
una bellissima descrizione, che leggo,
di che cos'è la Comunicazione
Aumentativa Alternativa:
"Tutte le volte che mi chiedono cos'è
la Comunicazione Aumentativa Alternativa,
dò sempre la stessa risposta:
è la voce di mio figlio".
Questo è di Michela, mamma di Stefano,
che mi sembra sintetizzi bene -
AR: Le definizioni,
quelle che dicono i genitori,
sono sempre molto sintetiche e belle.
FdB: Ecco adesso vediamo appunto
gli strumenti a cui hai accennato.
A.R.: Gli strumenti di comunicazione
vanno da strumenti semplici
a strumenti tecnologici.
Gli aspetti -
degli strumenti semplicissimi
sono dei simboli semplici,
dei simboli che rappresentano delle cose
e possono essere indicate
con gli occhi, con le mani
da bambini che non possono parlare,
anche in assenza dell'oggetto
che loro vorrebbero.
Questi simboli -
nella prima immagine avete visto una mamma
che propone una domanda al bambino
e il bambino può rispondere
indicando il si o il no.
I simboli spesso vengono assemblati
in tabelle di comunicazione
che sono assolutamente personali,
così come i sistemi simbolici.
Esistono tantissimi sistemi
simbolici nel mondo:
vengono assemblati in tabelle
che sono portabili se un bambino cammina,
[o] sul tavolino se non cammina.
E il bambino può indicarlo
con le mani, con gli occhi
o con delle tecniche di codifica.
Ci sono molti strumenti tecnologici:
vedete alcuni strumenti
che vengono chiamati VOCA,
da Voice Output Communication Aids.
Alcuni sono molto semplici:
si registra un messaggio,
la persona può schiacciare il tasto
ed emette il messaggio.
E veramente, tante volte
anche un semplice messaggio
dà a un bambino, o a un adulto,
il senso di esistere.
Io ricordo una bambina
che a 2 anni e mezzo
è stata ricoverata in ospedale
perché non respirava più,
è stata tracheostomizzata.
Una bambina che già parlava,
quando è stata ricoverata.
E ha gradito moltissimo
uno di questi tastoni a due messaggi
perché poteva dire alle infermiere
"vai via" quando venivano.
Quindi il senso di potere esistere
e potere, nell'ambiente,
decidere qualche cosa,
perché sono persone
che non possono decidere.
Ci sono, naturalmente,
strumenti a tecnologia semplice
e a tecnologia più sofisticata.
Stephen Hawking, lo conoscono tutti,
è un malato di SLA
che usa l'indicazione oculare
per selezionare messaggi, parole eccetera.
In genere non si sceglie
uno strumento solo,
ma noi diciamo un sistema di comunicazione
a seconda di partner comunicativi
e a seconda di quello che si vuole dire.
Con un sistema di comunicazione semplice
ma molto complesso
da adoperare per il partner,
una bambina con una pervicacia
[notevole] perché voleva sapere,
ha chiesto alla sua mamma
cosa le era successo alla nascita
per cui era in carrozzina,
quindi veramente permettono
di poter esistere.
FdB: Ecco, quest'ultima immagine
mi ricorda che mi hai detto
che Leonardo sta dialogando,
sta comunicando e sta -
AR: Leonardo è un bambino con una
sindrome gravissima, un ritardo mentale.
Però, dopo tanti anni che viene seguito,
qui lo vedete in giardino a una festa,
che apre la sua tabella
e dice quello che vuole,
quindi riesce ad essere autonomo.
I contenuti sono quelli suoi:
non cambia il carattere,
non lo fa cambiare.
Però dà il senso di esistere.
FdB: Nella prima immagine,
quando c'erano tante persone,
non so se avete notato
ma c'è una persona molto famosa
che è Hawking, il fisico,
il quale utilizza -
ha fatto anche uno speech a TED,
utilizza però una voce -
AR: Registrata, si -
FdB: Artificiale, non la sua.
Tu mi avevi detto che -
AR: Si, adesso abbiamo avuto, venerdì,
un convegno su Comunicazione
Aumentativa e SLA.
Ed è venuto un collega americano
che lavora al Children Hospital di Boston.
È uno specialista
in Comunicazione Aumentativa
che adesso ha trovato il modo,
lo fa da tanti anni,
di registrare, per questi malati,
moltissimi messaggi.
E lui riesce a farli registrare
a persone che hanno ancora la voce.
Molti chiedono "ma come fai?",
e lui dice "gli dico
che questi possono servire".
E poi parla dei software
che vengono adoperati
con indicazione oculare,
dove escono delle frasi
dette dal paziente,
dette con la propria voce.
Ci ha mostrato una signora
che chiama il suo cane;
e il cane, sentendo la voce, viene.
E poi ci sono tutti i messaggi,
io li chiamo i messaggi di legame,
gli ultimi messaggi detti
ai figli e ai propri cari.
FdB: Interessante quello
che hai accennato,
cioè che anche la tecnologia
e l'innovazione
aiutano moltissimo in questo modo.
E pensare che le tabelle che proponete
sono tabelle con le icone,
che poi sono entrate
nel linguaggio di interfaccia
con gli oggetti che usiamo oggi.
Però, a questo punto, [la domanda] è:
bastano gli strumenti?
AR: Ecco, c'è molta enfasi
sugli strumenti.
Gli strumenti, senza un progetto,
senza delle persone
che vogliano relazionarsi,
che diano tempo, che diano spazio,
che abbiano voglia di ascoltare,
che non invadano con la propria voce,
non servono a niente.
Infatti quello che conta è, veramente,
il lavoro con i partner comunicativi.
Altrimenti ci sono -
queste sono frasi di persone
che usano la Comunicazione Aumentativa,
però dicono: prima di tutto,
devono credere in noi;
e poi devono darci il tempo,
perché il tempo è molto importante.
Un malato di SLA diceva, recentemente,
che quando lui
sta componendo il messaggio,
tutti si mettono a parlare
perché non tollerano il silenzio.
E non tollerando il silenzio,
entrano a parlare.
E lui non solo non riesce
a finire il suo messaggio,
ma non può seguire la conversazione.
Il lavoro con i partner comunicativi
è essenziale e unico.
FdB: Eh, come quello che -
sei qui anche perché -
come interessa al mondo TED,
e la ragione per cui
ci sono i TED Talks è -
ma c'è anche una action
a cui avete pensato.
A.R: Sì -
FdB: che avete -
A.R: Non l'abbiamo pensata noi -
FdB: No, però -
A.R.: L'hanno pensata
in Canada, una action -
intanto questo ottobre
è il mese per la sensibilizzazione
della Comunicazione
Aumentativa Alternativa,
quindi qui cade a fagiolo.
E poi stanno facendo tante azioni,
tra cui una di fare questo logo
che dovrebbe venire esposto
nei negozi, nei teatri,
nei luoghi pubblici,
delle persone che sono disposte
ad ascoltare chi non parla,
utilizzando eventuali
strumenti di comunicazione,
senza rivolgersi all'accompagnatore.
E questo è molto importante
per la dignità e il senso di esistere
della persona disabile.
(Applausi)